einerseits genießt wissenschaft gerade
ja viel aufmerksamkeit andererseits sind
sie auch genervt davon dass
wissenschaftler ständig ihren kommen sie
auch nicht mehr mit weil die ständig
ihre meinung ändern dann haben wir die
lösung für sie heißen sie auf die
wissenschaft aber jetzt mal ernsthaft
wenn wissenschaft nicht die wahrheit
abbilden können und das kann sie nicht
warum dann überhaupt darauf hören na ja
ein wichtiges argument ist wissenschaft
bedeutet fortlaufend neue erkenntnisse
zu gewinnen
boal idioten legen sich auf eine meinung
fest wenn dem nicht so wäre würden wir
alle immer noch denken
aber wenn die ganz ehrlich sind das ja
nicht der einzige grund wissenschaft
steckt voller fehler und schwächen die
wissenschaftler sehr bewusst sind aber
von denen laien kaum was mitbekommen
deswegen möchte ich mich in diesem video
einmal ausgiebig diesen schwächen widmen
spoiler ich werde anschließend erklären
warum ich wissenschaft trotzdem
vertrauen
das könnt ihr auch gerne anders sehen
aber bevor er das in den kommentaren
loswerden hol durch einen tee macht es
euch gemütlich das haben wir heute alles
doch vor los geht's bevor wir uns
ausgiebig den schwächen der forschung
widmen möchte ich vorab ganz kurz klar
stellen warum wir ohne forschung
aufgeschmissen werden nur dass wir uns
da nicht falsch verstehen warum wir
forschung brauchen manche stellen sich
forschung vielleicht so vor obwohl
dieser lichtschalter funktioniert ihr
habt okay ist das reversibel das
reproduzierbar sehr schön aber meistens
läuft es in der forschung er so obwohl
dieser lichtschalter funktioniert obwohl
wenn wir mal ehrlich sind dort ist er so
zu weit ich ein lichtschalter gefunden
habe kann ich auch schon testen ob er
funktioniert ich bin kurz vor dem durch
klassisches beispiel ist die suche nach
einem neuen medikament darauf warten wir
ja während der pandemie besonders
ungeduldig im gegensatz dazu scheint das
finden geeigneter heilmittel laut
mancher internetforum
eigentlich ganz einfach ich hatte ganz
schwere migräne doch dann habe ich
dieses schweizer gletscherwasser mit
halber burke getrunken und es ging mir
direkt besser ist ein bisschen
unpraktisch aber es lohnt sich diese
denkt fallen endlich postrock ergo
procter übersetzt danach also dass wir
nur weil die mikroben nach dem rücken
wasser besser wurde heißt es doch nicht
automatisch dass sie wegen des gurken
wassers besser wurde so ein einzelner
selbstversuch hat also kaum aussagekraft
ganz viele selbstversuche allerdings
auch nicht bzw wenn man das internet
durchsucht findet man kein vollständiges
bild hunger ausprobiert bin immer noch
genau wie er schreibt darüber jetzt
schon ein blog artikel oder ein buch
stattdessen ist das netz voll von dingen
die angeblich super geholfen haben
doch da erfolge viel eher geteilt werden
kommt es zu einem sogenannten auswahl
weiß ein neues beschreibt allgemein eine
einseitige oder verzerrte wahrnehmung
oder darstellung die die realität nicht
richtig wiedergibt beim auswahl weiß
sehe ich nur eine bestimmte auswahl die
aber nicht die vollständige situation
widerspiegelt und das ist schlecht denn
wenn etwas bei 99 von 100 leuten nicht
funktioniert hat dann ist das natürlich
die vielen nützlichere info als der
bericht von dem ein dort wo es geklappt
hat gerade seit der pandemie haben nicht
wissenschaftlich belegte heilmittel
hochkonjunktur das haben wir zum
beispiel auch durch die aufruf zahlen
unseres mms videos gemerkt mms basiert
auf dem bleichmittel chlordioxid das im
körper eigentlich nichts verloren hat
trotzdem nehmen dass menschen ein oder
machen sich ein läufer damit weil es
gegen alles mögliche helfen soll von
autismus bis malaria und neuerdings
natürlich auch gegen korona und gerade
wenn man behauptet dass etwas vorbeugend
wirkt dann ist eine wirkung natürlich
besonders leicht eingebildet ich spiele
regelmäßig gleich mittel in den hintern
und habe immer noch kein corona denkt
mal drüber nach
das alles nur um klar zu machen dass
erfahrungsberichte leider wenig belegen
wir brauchen ordentliche forschung die
fehler und weißes von selbsttests und
erfahrungsbericht im netz kann man
abfangen durch ein ordentliches
studiendesign ja zum beispiel eine
testgruppe kriegt das medikament
kontrollgruppe gegen placebo die gruppen
sind ausreichend groß damit wenn der
statistische aussagekraft haben außerdem
haben wir auch schon ein paar mal über
statistische signifikanz gesprochen
sagen wie ihr mann testet ein
potenzielles co wird 19 medikament und
bei der testgruppe hören die symptome
ein kleines bisschen früher auf als bei
der kontrolle könnte das jetzt nur
zufall gewesen sein
klar könnte die frage ist wie hoch ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das nur
zufall war und dafür führt man
sogenannte statistische tests durch und
ermittelt den sogenannten signifikanz
wert oder p wert je kleiner der pea wird
desto unwahrscheinlicher ist es dass es
nur zufall ist also der p wert wären in
unserem beispiel die wahrscheinlichkeit
so einen unterschied zwischen den
gruppen auch bei einem völlig
wirkungslosen medikament zu sehen
wp wert liegt zwischen 0 und 11 0 1
entspricht einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
eins in zehn oder zehn prozent
die gleich 0,01 entspricht einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 in runde 4 1
prozent und so weiter man hat sich jetzt
auf eine wertgrenze diy nicht von der
man sagt so klein muss mindestens sein
damit man überhaupt es anfängt über eine
wirkung nachzudenken und zwar liegt
diese grenze bei p gleich
beziehungsweise kleiner 0,05 erst dann
betrachten wir einen unterschied als
statistisch signifikant com 05
entspricht einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
5% bzw 1 in 20 sowie die
wahrscheinlichkeit mit einem 20 seitigen
würfel eine eins zu würfen okay solche
wissenschaftlichen methoden dass man
kontrollgruppen hat dass man
statistische auswertungen macht und so
weiter es gibt ja noch mehr
das alles sorgt für die verlässlichkeit
und aussagekraft von wissenschaft gut
aber leider hat die wissenschaft noch
ihre ganz eigenen probleme die schwächen
der forschung fangen wir an mit etwas
offensichtliche was viele laien aber
nicht unbedingt auf dem schirm haben
nämlich fast alle hypothesen sind falsch
also das ist jetzt noch keine schwäche
das ist nun die einleitung zur ersten
schwäche aber als auch mal in der
forschung stellt man zunächst eine
hypothese auf also eine vermutung
hypothese schweizer gletscherwasser
metall burke hilft gegen migräne gut so
eine hypothese ist jetzt sehr random
aber sie ist es zwar und das jetzt
erstmal die hauptsache normalerweise
sind wissenschaftliche hypothesen
nachvollziehbar begründet oder plausibel
zum beispiel bei chur wird 19 kann eine
überschießende reaktion des immunsystems
probleme machen
der wirkstoff xmedia sohn dämpft das
immunsystem deswegen hypothese
dexamethason könnte bei schweren
verläufen das schlimmste verhindern
hypothesen werden als nächstes getestet
das heißt durch wissenschaftliche
studien auf die probe gestellt die
wissenschaft hat es aber an sich dass
die meisten hypothesen falsch sind also
wissenschaftler haben mit ihren
vermutungen über unerforschte
sachverhalte meistens unrecht meiner
wenn schon müsste bräuchte man ja nicht
erforscht in der regel muss man eine
idee nach der anderen
als falsch anerkennen er selbst mal
geforscht hat weiß wie ernüchternd
dieser prozess ist bis man irgendwann so
was kommt wo man feststellt das könnte
stimmen
aber was nicht funktioniert ist ja
genauso wichtig für den erkenntnisgewinn
wie was funktioniert
man irrt sich vorwärts deswegen ist das
wie gesagt keine schwäche sondern eine
stärke aber es ist wichtig dass auf dem
schirm zu haben um den ersten schwach
punkt zu verstehen erstens publication
beiß mal wieder eine hypothese nicht
aufgegangen ist dann wird das selten
veröffentlicht die sehr langweilig nicht
berichtenswert hat die kirchen weiß
heißt das positive ergebnisse viel
wahrscheinlicher veröffentlicht werden
als [ __ ]
negatives ergebnis kann zb sein ehe ich
teste ein medikament und kann keine
wirksamkeit feststellen schuld sind aber
nicht nur die wissenschaftler die
negative ergebnisse nicht so gerne an
die große glocke hängen ein
selbst wenn man eine studie
veröffentlichen möchte bei der und dann
stetig rausgekommen ist ja mir was
probiert hat aber nicht geklappt 2 ist
ja wichtig zu wissen selbst dann sagen
die fachzeitschriften also die journale
meistens das könnt ihr nicht bei uns
veröffentlichen wer interessiert sich
denn dafür dass es in vielerlei hinsicht
schlecht publication weiß kann dazu
führen dass positive ergebnisse völlig
überschätzt werden weil man die vielen
studien mit negativen ergebnissen nicht
zu sehen bekommt im schlimmsten fall
kann publication beiß dazu führen dass
etwas unwirksam ist als wirksam gilt
wenn es zum beispiel 20 studien
durchgeführt werden zu einem unwirksamen
medikament dann wird statistisch gesehen
in ungefähr einer dieser 20 studien doch
ein statistisch signifikantes ergebnis
rauskommen
erinnert euch in dem 20-seitigen würfel
wenn es aber diese eine studie die
einzige ist die veröffentlicht wird dann
sagt ja die studienlage dass dieses
wirkungslose medikament wirksam ist
durch den publication was passiert mit
der studienlage in der
wissenschaftlichen literatur etwas
ähnliches wie mit der anekdote lage auf
facebook ich hoffe niemand verlässt
vorzeitig dieses video und denkt sich
dann für immer
was ist forschung reich führen scheiß es
gibt auch lösungen für die probleme dazu
kommen wir aber erst später denn es gibt
ja noch viel mehr probleme
zweitens publikations druck
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
stehen unter hohem leistungsdruck gute
ergebnis rauszuhauen
das fängt spätestens in der doktorarbeit
an und wird nur krasser wenn man
anschließend versucht eine karriere in
der akademischen forschung zu verfolgen
an der uni oder einer
forschungseinrichtung kurz gesagt in
akademie und wer sich für akadimia
entscheidet hat in der regel eine
professur als ziel
doch obwohl sowieso nur die exzellente
ssten leute diesen weg einschlagen gibt
es am ende schlicht und einfach
nicht genügend professoren und bei all
dem druck wird akademische leistung
meistens nur in einer form gezählt
nämlich publikationen paper paper
publish or perish ist das motto
publizieren oder verreckt guten team
kombi mit der tatsache dass fast nur
positive ergebnisse publiziert werden
die eigentlich nicht erzogen werden
können ist dieser publikations druck
sehr bedauerlich so bedauerlich dass ich
schon mal ein ganzes video drüber
gemacht habe deswegen will ich hier nur
auf ein paar aspekte eingehen zum
beispiel schafft dieser druck anreize
dass wissenschaftler nicht den
interessantesten fragen nachgehen
sondern denen die am schnellsten
publizierte daten hervor bringen auch
wenn diese daten weniger relevant also
statt interessant das muss ich mit der
welt teilen wird es oft eher hand was
neu ist für meine publikationsliste
jetzt stellt euch vor eine doktorandin
hat ganz viel zeit und arbeit in ein
aufwändiges experiment gesteckt und
erhält ein nichts signifikantes ergeben
ist und sie steht womöglich noch unter
zeitdruck weil der vertrag ihrer
doktorarbeit bald aus wort und sie
danach nicht mehr bezahlt wird sie aber
publizieren muss um promovieren zu
können auch das ist leider ein sorry an
einigen unis die doktoranden hat dann
einen sehr hohen anreiz doch mal genau
an ihre daten rein zu schauen um zu
gucken ob da nicht doch irgendwo ein
signifikantes ergebnis rauszuholen ist
und ich waren jetzt nicht daran fälschen
also das passiert sicherlich auch
knallharte betrüger gibt es leider
überall aber das mache ich noch nicht
mal
drittens hecking und pi hätte der mann
eine hypothese wissenschaftlich testen
will darf man nicht die hypothese
anschließend anpassen oder ändern
nachdem man die ergebnisse gesehen ein
spiel ich möchte experimentell belegen
dass ich treffsicher beim daad bin bull
sei es auf 14 410 genau das war nicht
ich bin so in der wissenschaft nennt man
das hacking das steht für hypothetisch
erste results
wenn man im nachhinein die hypothese
anpasst so dass sie zu den ergebnissen
fast und von peking spricht man wenn man
so oft statistische tests durchführt bis
irgendwann ein statistisch signifikantes
ergebnis rauskommt nehme mir vor bei
spiele dann wird's klarer sagen wir ich
teste ein potenzielles medikament aber
es zeigt leider nicht die erhoffte
wirkung über den placebo-effekt hinaus
aber vielleicht wirkt es bei frauen
nicht leicht nur bei frauen mit locken
nur bei frauen mit locken die gerne
fernsehen und dann heißt das ergebnis
eben nicht mehr eine wirkung konnte
nicht nachgewiesen werden sondern bei
frauen mit locken die gerne big bang
theory schauen gibt es eine statistisch
signifikante wirkung dann tue ich so als
wollte ich die lockigen big bang theory
frauen von anfang an untersucht anderes
beispiel welche testen ob broccoli eine
reine haut macht ob also zwei gruppen
die eine ist jeden tag brokkoli die
kontrollgruppe nicht nur am ende kann
ich keinen unterschied in den haut rein
heiten feststellen zwischen den beiden
gruppen
aber ich kann ja immer noch schauen ob
sich der blutdruck verändert hat oder ob
sprit weniger worden ist oder ob die
fingernägel schnellere wachsen sie
irgendwo während sich die beiden gruppen
rein zufällig schon unterscheiden wenn
ich dann verkündet
broccoli macht längere fingernägel dann
ist das eine form des berges oder man
wiederholt das experiment einfach ganz
oft recht auch mit deinen abwandlungen
so lange bis irgendwann ein ph-wert
kleine 0,05 rauskommt wenn man nur oft
genug würfelt kommt halt früher oder
später nur eins raus wenn man dann eben
nur das statistisch signifikanter
ergebnis veröffentlicht und zu erwähnen
wie oft ist nicht signifikant war dann
ist es auch peking vor eine studie
publiziert werden darf muss sie erst den
peer review standhalten
das heißt der überprüfung und
begutachtung review durch fachleute
durch kollegen pierce hier habe ich peer
review als teil der qualitätskontrolle
in der wissenschaft erklärt aber das ist
leider nicht die ganze geschichte
caillou ist alles andere als
ein defekter prozess zum beispiel sind
zwar die review anonym
damit ich als autorin die jetzt nicht
quatschen kann oder sogar bestechen aber
andersrum wissen die reviewer oft von
wem das manuskript ist dass sie da
begutachten und klar gibt es da mal
review die bei ihren homies halt nicht
so genau hinschauen
oder andersrum die unbeliebten
konkurrenten das leben extra schwer
machen oder stellt euch vorher klicken
manuskript von der harvard university
dann macht es von anfang an einen
besseren eindruck als manuskript von
irgendeiner kleinen unbekannten uni
natürlich beeinflusst so was auch die
begutachtung also eine objektivität ist
nicht unbedingt gewährleistet
als letzten punkt dieser unvollständigen
liste will ich auf etwas corona
spezifisch sein gehen könnten
geschwindigkeit auf kosten von qualität
ja corona ungewöhnliche zeiten verlangen
ungewöhnliche maßnahmen in allen
bereichen auch über forschung da das
peer review lange dauert wird die meiste
corona forschung vorab auf sogenannten
preprint servern also vor druckservern
veröffentlicht oder sogar auf
pressekonferenzen kommuniziert es in
solchen krisenzeiten ungewöhnliche
publikations wege eingeschlagen werden
ist jetzt nicht unbedingt unangemessen
aber leider lässt sich auch nicht von
der hand weisen dass die dringlichkeit
neue erkenntnisse derzeit viele forscher
zu ja so quick and dirty studien
verleitet so nach dem motto besser
schlechte daten als gar keine und da
muss ich klar widersprechen also
schlechte daten sind schlimmer als gar
keine daten weil zum beispiel politische
entscheidungen dann mit gefühlter aber
falscher sicherheit getroffen werden
diese und weitere probleme werden in
diesem artikel kritisiert mit dem
untertitel krisen sind keine
entschuldigung um wissenschaftliche
standards zu senken das waren jetzt
einfach beispiele dafür dass es
wissenschaft nicht unfehlbar ist und
obwohl ich die liste auch noch
weiterführen könnte möchte ich euch
jetzt erklären warum ich wissenschaft
trotzdem vertraue ich hoffe ihr schaut
noch zu wissenschaft und forschung ist
genauso wenig perfekt wie
alles andere was menschen tun und
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ihren genauso wie andere menschen aber
dieses irren ist den wissenschaftlern
sehr bewusst und ich kenne keinen
anderen bereich in unserem leben der so
selbstkritisch ist wie die wissenschaft
also der diskussions teil des papers ist
voll von display mann und hinweisen auf
grenzen und schwächen grafen enthaltenen
fehler beugen und kompetenz intervalle
und wenn man eine frage beantwortet
nennt man im selben atemzug drei weitere
fragen die noch offen sind also
unsicherheiten werden in der
wissenschaft sehr stark betont und dass
wir jetzt gerade während corona einem
breiteren publikum viel ersichtlicher
während vor wissenschaft naja vielleicht
schon so ein bisschen unsichtbar im
elfenbeinturm betrieben wurde aber nur
weil wissenschaftler nicht nur ständig
irren sondern auch diese unsicherheiten
probleme und schwächen so sehr betonen
wäre es ein fehler daraus zu schließen
die haben ja auch keine ahnung ist wir
brauchen wir auch nicht auf sie zu hören
nein denn in allen anderen bereichen
unseres lebens wo wir keinen
wissenschaftlichen methoden folgen wären
wir natürlich mindestens genauso viel
und meistens viel mehr nur werden fehler
dort viel seltener eingeräumt oder
überhaupt erst selbstkritisch erkannt
wissenschaft ist nicht die wahrheit
aber sie ist die beste näherung die uns
zur verfügung steht
auch wenn die sanierung ein ständiger
prozess ist der niemals aufhören wie und
natürlich ist dieses selbstkritische
grundverständnis auch die beste
voraussetzung um sich zu verbessern wie
sich wissenschaft verbessern kann
gegen publication bei sh kinky hecking
hilft zum beispiel eine pre
registrierung von studien registrierung
bedeutet dass man vorab seine hypothese
und das studiendesign veröffentlicht so
kann man eben nicht mehr im nachhinein
zu tun das hätte man eigentlich ganz
andere hypothese gehabt oder sich
irgendwas statistische signifikanz
herbei rechnen
die man im ersten versuch so gar nicht
hat bei der zulassung neuer medikamente
ist eine pre registrierung zum glück
gängig im letzten video habe ich erwähnt
dass man in den usa klinische studien
für potenzielle medikamente pre
registrieren muss um zu vermeiden dass
unwirksame oder sogar schädliche
medikamente zugelassen werden außerhalb
der medikamentenzulassung ist pre
registrierung aber nichts standard
sollte es aber werden also manche
görners setzen dass bereits voraus und
man kann hoffen dass andere nachziehen
wohlgemerkt ist eine pre registrierung
alleine noch kein gütesiegel war quasi
jeder eine studie pre registrieren kann
egal wie unsinnig sein schönes beispiel
von dem vorhin erwähnten heimische
chlordioxid da gibt es diese pre
registrierung einer studie über
chlordioxid gegen cockpit 19
der plan ist 20 cupid 19 patienten mit
dem bleichmittel chlordioxid zu
behandeln ohne kontrollgruppe um zu
zeigen dass dadurch die krankheit besser
wird das natürlich großer quark weil
profit 19 bei den meisten patienten zu
glück mild verläuft und von alleine wer
geht egal ob man gleich mit geschluckt
oder schweizer gletscherwasser halben
google dringt deswegen kann man noch
einen schritt weitergehen und so
genannte registered reports einführen
hier werden vor beginn der studie die
geplanten methoden einem kompletten peer
review unterzogen so was wäre die studie
schon fertig und wenn die review mit
allem zufrieden sind verpflichtet sich
das journal dazu diese studie am ende zu
publizieren egal was dabei rauskam dass
natürlich auch eine starke methode gegen
publication weiß und immer mehr jobs
bieten diese möglichkeit inzwischen auch
an das waren jetzt nur ein paar
beispiele von vielen wie man durch
etablieren von kontrollprozessen
wissenschaft besser machen kann
das alles wird nie ausreichen um
wissenschaft perfekt oder unfehlbar zu
machen
aber solange man sich den grenzen
wissenschaftlicher erkenntnis bewusst
ist ist wissenschaft für komplizierte
gesellschaftlich relevante fragen die
verlässlichste entscheidungsgrundlage
die wir haben
das ist meine meinung also wie geht es
euch nach diesem video habt ihr jetzt
mehr oder weniger vertrauen in die
wissenschaft heißt ihr meiner meinung
seit und auch findet dass wissenschaft
trotz aller fehler und schwächen
vertrauen verdient hat teilt gerne
dieses video und hier kommt ihr noch zum
vollen aufklärungs video über das
angebliche heilmittel mms
beziehungsweise chlordioxid falls ihr in
eurem bekanntenkreis davon hört weil es
angeblich gegen grone hilft bitte teil
dieses video und hier kommt ihr für die
volle science ladung zu einem unserer
lieblings 1 kann jede kurz gesagt wir
sehen uns in zwei wochen und bis dahin
bleibt sicher